entrepreneurs doivent user d'imagination
pour soutenir leurs employés faire
survivre leur entreprise ces jours ci on
voit si deux de ces entrepreneurs ce
soir se fit boulanger présidente de bon
look et nicolas duvernois président de
pur vodka
bonsoir à vous deux parents sont aussi
friands
alors d'abord parlé nous un petit peu
avant de parler des solutions vous avez
apporté mais de l'impact de la fermeture
de vos commerces de l'impact de ce qui
se passe présentement se fit boulanger
d'abord oui donc nous notre entreprise
et est bon look est un détaillant de
lunettes de prescription est
présentement nos activités en magasin
sont complètement reste arrêter une
nourrice que les ventes web juste de lui
ni dé longue date de lundi le 6 mars on
a dû fermer nos 35 magasins dans 11
villes à travers le pays et s'est
entraîné la mise à pied temporaire de
400 de nos employés travers le canada
je cacherai pas évidemment que c'est un
grand drame pour nous comme entrepreneur
mon frère et moi et là bas on sent une
responsabilité comme un employeur de
trouver des alternatives pour nos
employés pour qu'ils se sentent on va en
parler dans un instant c'est quoi
l'impact pour vous une colonne vernois
nous on est tout petit peu plus de
chance il ya les magasins en amérique du
nord
cependant on a été frappé durement par
l'art est carrément total de nos ventes
en asie comme en europe
on a des employés en france qui sont
confinement obligatoire et c'est sûr que
depuis la fermeture des restaurants et
des bars à montréal du jour au lendemain
on a perdu quand même un bon un gros
avenue suite à cette fermeture se fit
boulanger expliquez nous ce que vous
avez donc décidé de faire avec vos
employés et avec l'entreprise good food
oui donc on a fait appel à notre réseau
d'affaires j'ai appuyé jonathan ferrari
le président de coups de feu qui est une
entreprise établie à montréal tu fais
dans les repas prêts à cuisiner et juste
vous donner un peu une idée là pour eux
de l'ampleur l'association cherche
présentement à embaucher 500 personnes
dans trois grandes villes canadiennes
donc on a discuté avec leur département
des ressources humaines afin de mettre
kg rapidement un type de contrôles
temporaires pour emblème pour qu'ils
embauchent nos employés pour quelques
semaines et ça permet à nos employés de
conserver le lien d'emploi à long terme
avec boulot car on s'entend on le répète
pour nous c'est des mises à tiques sont
temporaires les gens sont encore nos
employés puis même si si c'est la
concevoir et voir une fin à cette crise
et on souhaite évidemment rappelé nos
employés pour la relance mais donc
voulait prêter à good food un peu en
quelques sorte oui et vous avez contacté
loblaw a également également
donc on a contacté les gens chez loblaws
sont dans plusieurs grandes villes
canadiennes nous on est dans 11 villes
dont on a des employés un peu partout à
travers le canada et une bannière comme
loblaws ne peut vraiment répondre au
niveau géographique l'eau à plus de gens
chez boulot mais on s'entend que de de
faire des lunettes ou d'être opticiens
c'est quand même différent que de faire
des repas oui mais en effet on a 47
obtient travers le canada dont aussi
beaucoup d'employés qui font d'autres
types de tard son nom des gens et qui
travaille en magasin on a déjà vu au
chef au centre de distribution
on a des gens à notre centre d'appels
alors important noté aussi que good food
et loblaw a remporté seulement des
emplois
en magasin pardon à 100 de distribution
pour parquer des repas ils ont par
exemple des besoins pour leurs centres
d'appels donc c'est des emplois qui sont
à la maison autour des employés qui
voudrait par exemple pas être en contact
avec le public
nicolas duvernois vous avez vous
totalement transformer vos cuves de
votre cas pour faire du désinfectant
expliquez nous comment on fait ça oui
bah mince avec un autre partenaire
michel jodoin de toujours qu on a décidé
de transformer en quelques jours
totalement la production pour prendre
tout ce qui était de vodka et faire du
désinfectant à mains que j'ai eu l'idée
en parlant de trois amis qui travaillait
au temps la saq à l'urgence de l'hôpital
sainte justine et qui me disait qu'il
n'avait pas cet équipement passé de
désinfectant à mains sachant que
l'ingrédient principal pour ce produit
là c'est de l'alcool je me suis
immédiatement dit la vodka pure
attendent la lutte au virus est beaucoup
plus importante donc on a décidé de s'y
mettre à une vitesse exceptionnelle
d'ailleurs je remercie mon équipe et
celle de monsieur joueront pour avoir
réussi à faire ce coup de circuit et
donc vous utiliser l'alcool que vous
avez pour faire des désinfectants chessa
exactement mais vu que nos ventes ont
été ralenties en europe et en asie on
avait de l'alcool dans les cuves et puis
on s'est dit bon temps car en bouteilles
etc a continué d'embouteiller nos
produits surtout pour votre cas on a dit
bon on va prendre cet alcool là et puis
on va développer une recette de
désinfectant mais on attend la dernière
étape qui est celle de l'homologation du
maire de santé canada et on espère d'une
minute à l'autre l'a littéralement d'une
d'une heure à l'autre savoir chiper
comme on dit les premières comment ça va
si vite que ça à voir l'homologation
il ya un programme accéléré quand le
premier ministre a demandé aux
entreprises de huy de lever la main
qu'il pouvait aider il ya un programme
qui a misé ans et qui a été mise en
place accélérée pour avoir une
homologation pour ce type de produit là
j'imagine que système centrale nucléaire
ça sera un peu plus long mais la recette
est relativement simple grand grand
grand challenge c'est la complexité de
d'acheter des ingrédients pour faire
cette recette et là vous arriver à
produire combien mais là cette fois ci
on a produit quatre mille litres comme
pour une première production 4000 litres
ça doit répondre à 0 01 % de la demande
on espère sincèrement qu'on va pouvoir
pouvoir trouver un de l'éthanol
finalement c'est l'éternel dénaturer qui
nous manque pour pouvoir produire en
plus gros volumes
on peut produire en plus gros volume
donc tellement une grosse demande il ya
vraiment des besoins essentiels mais
quand je descends ciel genre l'urgence
des hôpitaux parce que il faut il faut
vraiment qu'on consomme est là madame
boulanger est ce que vous trouvez que
les soutiens d'ottawa de québec sont
satisfaisants compte tenu des
circonstances
écoutez je pense que les deux
gouvernements font en ce moment est ce
qu'ils peuvent avec la sur la situation
qui évolue à tous les jours le nous
c'est certain qu'on trouve que le
gouvernement logo a vraiment a les deux
mains sur le volant
je pense que le en somalie les personnes
en place en croco au ministère
l'économie comprennent bien la réalité
des entrepreneurs donc nous on est en
contact avec nos banquiers évidemment
puis un tout les intervenants du milieu
dont je pense que le milieu des affaires
en ce moment se mobilisent pour lui
trouver des solutions en quelques mots
monsieur duvernois elle entièrement
raison je vois énormément
d'entrepreneurs et chefs d'entreprise
qui se mobilisent pour tout de suite
essayé
premièrement d'éviter le pire et tout de
suite on repense déjà à comment on va
faire pour rebâtir cette économie car à
distance largement impacté donc
sincèrement c'est extrêmement motivant
et j'encourage encore tout le monde de
consommer des produits locaux
acheter un produit si c'est un
investissement acheter un produit
d'ailleurs c'est une dépense c'est bien
dit ça nicolas duvernois sophie
boulanger merci et bravo la recherche sa
route mais